there's an internet trend that you've
been very excited about which one photos
matching paintings yes
photos matching paintings and I
understand that you've done you've
started to do this you enjoy it yes
people are like oh what face do I look
like perhaps it is I don't know like an
apricot in a bowl or something yes well
I'm thinking why not just if I want to
do it I should do you know you can lead
a horse to the water but why not just
take the water and pour it on your face
that makes no sense what you just said
I'm telling you is your American friend
yes that's not larger that makes unless
you're a horse yeah
I'm not a horse yeah yeah I mean we have
some cheat some DNA similarity all right
listen
well let's get bad yeah yes keeping you
on track is very difficult I'm sorry
about this Conan yeah I'm so excited
it's a subpoena microphone yeah yes it's
a real microphone is it working right
now
I I think they can yes chicky chicky
what what oh oh nasty that worked fine
that was beautiful thank you everyone
loves it chicky chicky watch yeah yeah
yeah shimmy shimmy Coco what of Germany
yes very good yes don't know what you're
talking about
internet trend and so you've been
assimilating making yourself look like
famous paintings let's see the first one
let's take this here there you are oh
the thinker yes the thinker someone said
no more like the stinker okay yes yes
that is very lame this yeah very and
what's the next one the next one is oh
you're one of those dogs in the dogs
playing poker yes she's got a very
suspicious to face I want his cheating
perhaps
I have a full-house Porter go away and
then what's the last moment if we have
one last one right here
oh girl with the Pearl Earring post
poison the Pearl you think it's just one
for you
mmm foil or not your box or just
aluminum foil yes yes very cheap you'd
love that kind of look don't you I like
it I like if I'm endorsed and still
require sunglasses for my own body yeah
Jiffy Pop ha ha you have what is that
it's when the popcorn in they would send
them from the olden times remember Andy
and they're the seller it would pop up
and then you cut it open in popcorn
would just come out of your chest
oh it's poison look look at each are you
wearing what is that all the colors of
the rainbow have you seen the Crayola
box of 64 yeah this is 52 52 of the 64
the other favorite downtown
wait I don't want it I will wait on that
yeah
you